I'm looking forward to get inspired by
all these different speakers I'm super
proud that we will begin a conference
with over 36 talks and the keynote and
the beautiful location it's a great
location I mean there's lots of water
around us I came in with a boat this
morning it's just a great place to get
inspired there's a little light here we
originally thought this was gonna be a
200-person event and ended up being a
300 person event so we're very excited
things like deep learning but also more
traditional things like data analysis
and how to store your data and spark and
Julia
think like the knowledge-sharing instead
of going to overprice conferences I like
I like it very much I think it's very
inspiring to see all of this intelligent
people gathered in one room
brilliant been working mostly in art up
till this point so I'm hoping to learn
in which ways fighting is faster people
come to us and tell us how useful it is
to them which is always it's always
exciting to know that the work we're
doing is is useful to people people are
amazingly friendly I've had great
conversations with lots of attendees
from all over and I've definitely gotten
what I wanted out of it which was to
meet people both working on similar
problems but also to get very new ways
of thinking about my problems I gave a
tutorial for face recognition and my
extreme was great that people was really
enthusiastic they were able also to
follow hands on what I was doing I mean
that phantom community has to be
together in order to advance because why
would you do things twice so here you
can learn and may be interested in
something and somebody already did it
right and then you can you can share it
with them and that's a really great
experience for me and it gets me
inspired I wanted to try and sort of
improve the the Python experience for
for spark users so that they could they
could really use the tools they were
familiar with and I'm sort of working to
make it so that the API was more more
full-featured
I actually I started a project with one
of my friends Juliette who was at
Cloudera house where we focused on that
but in addition to that while we were
working on this project you know I found
lots of things too that I kept wanting
to fix in in pi spark itself and so
while while our project didn't live on
like my my interest in improving PI
spark itself has very much lived on and
continued
yeah the idea was to bring those people
together and since Amsterdam is centre
of a lot of this ecosystem we thought
that bringing people together here was
the best place to make the ecosystem
tribe and also the diversity of people
present justifies them I really love the
PI data community and it's like one of
my favorite conferences and just people
are so friendly